I mean what's fascinating about this
report is it reveals actually a picture
that I think we weren't familiar with
it's not about north-south divides it's
not about in a city versus suburban it's
actually the coastal regions rural towns
are really suffering the good news is
that there seems to be an excellent
impact on inner-city areas particularly
to do with good schooling good transport
links so there's hope but it requires
money so I think the big question is
going to be are we going to see that
kind of investment and of course the
other aspect of it is about jobs yeah
quite hugely concentrated not just in
the southeast but particular in London
in some of these areas like Somerset for
example is that something that's
realistic are we going to see jobs
available in the near future well I mean
you'd think so with an area like that
because of course Hinkley Point nuclear
power stations being built there I mean
that's going to create thousands of jobs
shortly for the local economy I think
that's one of the biggest problems is
that a there aren't high aspirations in
many cases this is a lot to do with
teaching not necessarily good schools in
some areas but also very bog-standard
not good enough transport links I mean
really practical things that are having
a big impact so on the one hand it's
about aspirations it's about knowing
about opportunities on the other hand
it's literally being able to get to them
and this is the problem though I mean
London just dominates everything I mean
for example yesterday we have the
industrial strategy Greg Clark unveiling
a big investment by Merck the u.s. drug
giant and it's all in London it is we've
got to change the home I think that the
reality is that any kind of policy that
a social policy is also economic policy
if we're trying to solve any of these
social issues around aspirations social
mobility we've got to look at the
economy and let's really recognize the
economy isn't just something that
affects those people in London there's a
whole other rest of the country out
there worth pointing out though contrary
to popular belief in equality in the UK
as a whole is actually falling isn't it
it is and I think that's one of the
things that they're at pains to
emphasize there is a good news story in
there I mentioned inner city areas I
mean that's a real success story
in many cases there was very high levels
of disadvantage there still is
unfortunately in other cases but there's
real a real strong sense about social
mobility improving so there is
definitely good change but I think it's
that there are forgotten areas and I
think that's one of the stronger things
about this report we now know where they
are now we can cause and alright I'm
state evolved from Civitas good to see
you thanks for joining me